estos adolescentes hacen parte de los
70.000 refugiados ucranianos que
cruzaron a territorio rumano huyendo de
la guerra viajaron sin sus padres y
ahora están bajo custodia de esta
institución de cuidado infantil en rabat
y una pequeña localidad en el noreste de
rumanía
la da tiene 17 años proviene de jarquín
una ciudad ucraniana golpeada por los
ataques rusos todavía está traumatizada
por lo vivido
esta es mi casa ahí donde están las dos
ventanas es una habitación está
completamente destruida la gente trata
de limpiar los escombros pero todo quedó
destruido
34 menores ucranianos no acompañados
como vlada han sido alojados en este
centro infantil de rumanía desde la
invasión rusa ucrania 5 de ellos
continúan aquí después de huir de los
bombardeos sacha tiene 17 años intenta
encontrar un respiro pero aquí lejos de
su familia en kiev está solo y enfrente
un futuro incierto
no me siento bien no entendemos lo que
está pasando en ucrania la economía está
destruida no tenemos idea de lo que
haremos en el futuro no hay sentido de
perspectiva la gente está muriendo solo
tienes el 17 y estás en medio de todo
esto y no tienes idea de qué harás con
tu vida pero para crina popescu
directora del centro infantil la
seguridad es la máxima prioridad para
estos menores vulnerables en forma de
acher trafic de personas anual el mayor
riesgo es la trata de personas y otras
prácticas ilícitas
practicar ese práctica
tenemos que estar completamente seguros
de que se mantengan protegidos y que no
se les deje solos en las calles
bien seguro que esos de seguro todos
estos menores no acompañados obtuvieron
una protección temporal otorgada a los
ucranianos por la unión europea han
recibido visas y alojamiento en rumanía
y en ocasiones logran olvidar por un
momento la guerra datacash hoy es el
cumpleaños de nuestra querida amiga
valerie así que hemos puesto la mesa
charlamos y nos reímos entre nosotros
como hacen los buenos amigos
muchas
[Música]
para valeri que cumple 18 años hoy es un
mito ahora que es adulta decidió que su
camino hacia el futuro conduce al oeste
a alemania lo que significa comenzar una
nueva vida lejos de los horrores de la
guerra